Take a break!
If you find yourself stuck on something
if you find yourself unable to make progress
on a project that you’re working on
take a break.
Because often if you’re just trying to ram something through
you’re not going to get the results that you’re looking for
and if you take 10 minutes
go away from it and come back
you’ll often be refreshed
and be able to solve the problem.
Two quick stories for you that happened to me recently
so yesterday Jason who was helping me with my new website
and all the branding that goes with it
he’s working on some coding problem
something on the website
some bug that he’s trying to work through
and he couldn’t find a solution.
And he’s spending like an hour on this thing
and I just see him on the computer like
“Ugh”, rubbing his eyes
and unable to make progress on this thing.
And so he does a smart thing
and he goes and he takes a break.
He goes out, goes for a walk
get some food, comes back
and within 5 minutes of sitting down again he solves it.
And this happens to me so much
and I don’t know what it is about the human condition
that allows us to do this
but I often find myself with these kinds of problems
and I may come back with the next day
or maybe it’s the next day
but the solution often comes really quickly
after taking a break.
So again, if you’re finding yourself pounding away with something
and you’re just not making progress
you just can’t figure out what the problem is
take a break, even like 10, 15 minutes
and come back to it.
Another quick example is in salsa dancing.
I love salsa dancing,
I love teaching people how to dance as well
and I was working with a student
teaching her how to do some turns
and she just wasn’t getting it.
And so I said, “Okay you know what, it’s okay.
It’s okay, we’ll come back to it
we’ll move on to other stuff.”
And it was an hour that I was with her
and we did other moves
and at the end of the hour we came back
and we did the turn again and she got it.
And so the first example was programming, business related.
This was salsa dancing, personal, a new skill.
Anytime you’re trying to figure something out
if you’re doing it over and over and over again
and it’s just not working out for whatever reason
I don’t know why this happens
but if you’re not making progress, stop
and come back to it later that day
or the next day
and you’ll amaze yourself with how you’re able to quickly make progress
and think “Why didn’t I think of that before?”
So take a break.
Believe.
For those of you watching you liked the video
please give it a thumbs-up below.
It always makes me want to do more for you
and please leave a comment underneath.
Let me know what you think.
I really love seeing the comments come in.
They make my day.
They’re so important to me every day.
It makes me keep going and doing these for you.
So please leave a comment
and if you have a question, leave it below.
I’ll do a video response.
Thank you guys, I’ll see you soon.